[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to once
again be discussing the wealth
of harry potter now it shouldn't come as
a surprise to anyone
that harry was rich filthy rich
i mean maybe he wasn't malfoy rich or
lestrange rich
but he certainly had enough money money
which he was able to
expertly preserve throughout the course
of the films by having everything
bought for him seriously harry didn't
have to buy
anything hedwig hagrid nimbus 2000
mcgonagall firebolt sirius we're
introduced to harry's masters of gold at
the very beginning of the series
when hagrid brings him to gringotts and
shows him vault
687 when harry walks in he's visibly
gobsmacked by the sheer volume of coins
in front of him
a veritable assault on his senses the
family wealth started with the founding
patriarch of the family
and infrared of stingcombe a 12th
century potioneer
was quite successful in the potions
business harry's grandfather fleemont
potter
continued the family business and made a
fortune of his own living it all to
harry's father
james this meant that naturally when
james died
the fortune must have to harry the
fortune of centuries of successful
potioneers
so now i think a good question is what
did harry actually do with his money
did he use it to philanthropically did
he use it to
help the weasleys i mean they were the
family that took him in as one of their
own
they also happened to struggle
financially i think i see an obvious use
for his money here
in stuck contrast with harry we have the
weasleys
who were poor and i mean poor it wasn't
that arthur had a bad job
it was just that him and molly had so
many children
seven sets of school supplies seven sets
of clothes and seven mouths to feed
eight if you include harry's arthur's
salary had to cover
a lot their financial situation became
so dire that
weasley almost became synonymous with
poor
something which draco so fondly reminded
them of whenever he had the chance
think my name is funny do you well no
need to ask yours
red hair and a hand-me-down robe you
must be a weasley
molly didn't work either which was part
of the problem
but in all fairness they did have seven
children
and i'm sure that's no easy task taking
care of them
and keeping them all organized however i
suppose she must have had a bit of a
break when the kids were at hogwarts
right the bottom line is they had no
money so my question is
did harry ever help them out did he ever
shell out some of that fortune to the
family
that was arguably more deserving of it
than anyone else
for quite some time ron weasley harry's
best friend
went without a wand because it had
broken this hindered his education
and his family couldn't afford to
replace it so why on earth
didn't harry give ron money for a new
wand i can sort of see why harry might
feel uncomfortable
overtly handing over cash to ron but why
couldn't he have
surprised him with a new wand why
couldn't he have sent money to
molly arthur to purchase it for him i
get that the wheezies are proud
and may not want to take money from
harry but by paying for the wand harry
would simply be compensating them for
something that was his fault in the
first place
it doesn't make a lot of sense it's an
uncomfortable affair
harry may have felt odd giving ron money
and i'm willing to bet that ron would
feel odd taking that money
but why didn't harry do it through the
teachers what about
anonymously furthermore hogwarts offers
financial aid which covers expenses
related to materials
school supplies so why didn't ron the
weasleys
take advantage of that as it turns out
the reason that ron didn't apply for
financial aid
is probably the same reason that they
wouldn't accept money from harry
morley's pride
that lot won't come cheap said george
with a quick look at his parents
lockhart's books are really expensive
well we'll manage
said mrs weasley but she looked worried
i think that part of this pride stems
from the fact that they actually had
some money
it was just stretched so much among the
family members that it made things
difficult
arthur had a respectable salary it just
wasn't enough to cover
everyone comfortably had they actually
been properly poor
then maybe she would have been more
receptive to the financial aid available
to them
so harry didn't shell out for ron's wand
but did he ever help them out
financially
i think that namely because of their
pride the weasley family would have
never accepted money from him
however there was one instance in which
harry was able to help them out
specifically fred and george however
harry did have to
hide this donation to the twins from
molly
this was because a she wouldn't have
approved of them taking money from harry
and b she didn't necessarily think that
opening a joke shop was a viable career
option for them
harry grinned he had forced the weezy
twins to take the thousand gallons prize
money he'd won in the triwizard
tournament
to help them realise their ambition to
open a joke shop
but he was still glad to know that his
part in furthering their plans
was unknown to mrs weasley she did not
think running a joke shop was a suitable
career
for two of her sons another thing to
consider is that harry himself
felt awkward about his fortune stashed
away at gringotts
money in abundance that he never had to
earn himself
this is supported by the following
quotes harry said nothing
he felt a bit awkward stored in an
underground vault at gringotts in london
was a small fortune that his parents had
left him also
harry felt even worse when they reached
his vault he tried to block the contents
from view
as he hastily shoved handfuls of coins
into a leather bag
at the end of the day i think that what
this really boils down to is the fact
that the weezies would have never
accepted harry's money
even if he had offered harry was
uncomfortable about his wealth to begin
with
and this uncomfortability meant that he
rarely even thought about it
furthermore a young boy offering money
to a respectable employee of the
ministry of magic
and the parents of his best friend is
just somehow inappropriate money is
weird and divisive
so it wasn't that harry was greedy not
at all he was just trying to be
considerate and respectful of their
pride
to add to that another thing to consider
is that harry wasn't really money-minded
it wasn't something that had ever
occurred to him because he basically
always had it with the dursleys he was
fed provided clothes and given shelter
and was abused so much that he wasn't
ever really given a proper opportunity
to find out about things that he may
have wanted things beyond the essentials
harry's a kind and good person but he
was thrown into wealth while he was
still very young
which meant that he never truly
understood the importance of money until
much later on
it must have felt like play money to
harry entering a magical world
where he was able to afford any and
everything all without having to work a
day in his life
it took harry time to learn about the
relationship between time and money
and how much someone would have to work
to be able to afford the things he could
buy
by snapping his fingers it was in such
abundance that it wasn't often on his
radar
he didn't have to think about it
children don't necessarily equate
time with effort and by the time harry
truly realized the significance of the
pile of gold he was sitting on
he had formed such a strong relationship
with ron that it would have been
bitterly inappropriate to downplay that
friendship by offering him substantial
sums of money
anyway i hope that answers the question
as to why harry never gave the weasleys
money of course with the exception of
the funds he provided to fred and george
for their joke shop
that's it for today's video if you
enjoyed it please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time
as much money in life as you could want
the two things most human beings would
choose above all
the trouble is humans do have a knack of
choosing precisely those things that are
worst for them
you